ah yeah today we are learning English
with Beauty and the Beast you are going
to watch some scenes from the movie
alongside interview with actress Emma
Watson you're going to greatly improve
your British pronunciation learn tons of
vocabulary grammar and so much more
if you're new here this is how the
lesson will work you'll watch some clips
with subtitles
then we'll teach you all of the most
important vocabulary pronunciation and
cultural context before you test
everything you learn by watching it a
final time without subtitles and
answering some quiz questions let's get
started
beating the Beast really if you think
about it is like for movies in one it's
an action movie we're making a
live-action film there's a huge amount
of stunts and there's a wolf fighting
and horse riding and you know and guns
and sword fights and all of that going
on it's also a comedy the comic timing
of characters like Cogsworth and Lumiere
and mrs. Potts
it's just hysterical in my opinion and
then on the other hand it's a romance
it's a romantic drama so and then it's a
musical
and then there's music just to just kind
of really added on the top music and
dance and theater really isn't the only
bookworm in town so where did you run
off to this week two cities in northern
Italy I didn't want to come back are you
got any new places to go I'm afraid not
but you may reread any of the old ones
that you'd like thank you your library
makes a small corner of the world feel
big
beating the Beast really if you think
about it is like full movies in one the
Beast is an animal especially a large
dangerous or unusual one in the movie
and other fantasy stories beast is used
to refer to beasts like monsters
for example a half-man half-animal by
saying that Beauty and the Beast is for
movies in one Emma means that the film
can be seen and enjoyed from four
different perspectives which you will
explain in this interview example this
jacket is actually two in one is rain
jacket but it can also be used in formal
situations beating the Beast really if
you think about it is like full movies
in one it's an action movie we're making
a live action film in filmmaking live
action is a production that shows real
people acting as opposed to animations
or computer-generated effects the
original Beauty and the Beast is an
animation Emma is saying that they were
making a live-action film and that it
was also an action movie recently Disney
has been making lots of live-action
films of their Animated Classics have
you checked out our lessons with the
lion king and alladin yet there's a huge
amount of stunts and there's a wolf
fighting and horse riding and you know
and guns and sword fights and all of
that going on stunts is an exciting
moment of action usually in a film that
is dangerous or Pierce dangerous and
usually needs to be done by someone
skilled here and we uses the noun wolf
fighting meaning a fight with wolves
when collocated like that you can create
a variety of different nouns example
most people coming to this gym prefer
weightlifting over cardio exercises
she also says a horse riding which is
also a noun referring to the activity of
riding horses so in another example if a
film wins awards we could say it is an
award-winning film it's also a comedy
the comic timing of characters like
Cogsworth and Lumiere
and mrs. Potts it's just hysterical in
my opinion comic timing is the concept
that things can be funnier when done or
said at the correct speed and with
pauses check out our Chandler from the
TV series friends tries to be funny by
adding pauses and speaking at specific
speed which he'll say jokes or the
things he says to sound more funny I
went to that tanning place your wife
suggested was that place the son Donald
Duck never wore pants but whenever he's
getting out of shower he always puts a
towel around his waist
I mean what is that about you might have
noticed the comedians like Ellen
DeGeneres also do this you're an amazing
actress you're not not one but two
nominated films tonight you were in
that's just is so what is the word for
it selfish I guess I really do think
it's an exceptional year wouldn't you
like to be able to understand the jokes
when you watch your favorite TV series
and movies in English well our food with
friends course can help you a lot in
this 48 week course that follows along
with the first two seasons of friends we
will help you to understand every single
joke plus you get 20 plus page P of
power lessons
vocabulary memorization software access
to our fluency circle global community
and so much more what are you waiting
for it you can try it for free with our
three-part master class all you have to
do is click up here or down in
description below to learn more and sign
up it's also a comedy the comic timing
of characters like Cogsworth and Lumiere
and mrs. Potts
it's just hysterical in my opinion
someone who is hysterical is so excited
angry or in panic that they start to
scream without control now if something
is considered hysterical it simply
causes people to become uncontrolled in
such a way most commonly we say this to
mean that something is very funny and
makes you laugh a lot as Emma does here
it's just hysterical in my opinion and
then on the other hand it's a romance
it's a romantic drama the expression on
the other hand is used when you want to
give another point or fact about
something that is really different from
what you said before mother was there
for me at a time when no one else was
not only was she a singularly gifted
witch she was also an uncommonly kind
he had a way of seeing the beauty you
know this even and perhaps most
especially and that person could not see
it in themselves
your father James on the other hand yeah
shall we say talent for trouble
then on the other hand it's a romance
it's a romantic drama when talking about
types of movies and TV series drama
first two highly emotional ones that are
focused on emotional serious situations
and interactions between characters not
on comedy or action scenes so emma is
saying that the movie is a comedy but
also on the other hand is a romantic
drama uh if it isn't the only bookworm
in town bookworm is an informal way to
call person who is constantly reading
books your father and I be friends it's
time to get I wanted to throw up yeah so
where did you run off to this week if
you run off to a place you are suddenly
leaving the place you are and escaping
to go somewhere else the Beast wouldn't
hurt anyone I've heard of the effects of
dark magic but I've never before seen it
with my own eyes this is a threat to our
very existence
we can't ever running off to warn the
Beast knock her up too
the man is asking Bell about the story
she discovered in the last book she read
and where it happened where did you run
off for this week to cities in northern
Italy I didn't want to come back so Bell
responds that she ran off to two cities
in northern Italy she might be making a
reference to the popular story of Romeo
and Juliet which took place in the north
of Italy are you got any new places to
go I'm afraid not
although afraid means the same as scared
here I'm afraid is a polite expression
used before telling someone something
that might make them sad disappointed or
angry an example would John be there I'm
afraid not things haven't been going
very well here I'm afraid of course I
came back I'll never leave you again
Fred it's my turn to leave immediately
Professor Dumbledore is not here he
received an urgent out from the Ministry
of Magic and left immediately for London
are you got any places to go I'm afraid
not
but you may read any of the old ones
that you'd like thank you to reread is
to read something again Bell has read
all the books in the library and so now
is rereading them your library makes us
small corner of the world feel big the
way Bell uses corner here is to refer to
an area of a country or land often
somewhere quiet or far away example it's
important to meet people from outside of
your corner of the world in order to
broaden your global perspective
[Music]
you need someone at the helm of a movie
like this they couldn't really do all of
those things and it takes someone quite
special I think to to get all of that
working very well and I think bill has
done a brilliant job of that we wanted
to make sure that we know she loves
reading when I shop to travel but we
also wanted to give her this element of
being quite industrious and quite
practical and very inventive laundry was
amazing are you doing teaching another
girl to read isn't one enough
you need someone at the helm of a movie
like this they couldn't really do all of
those things if you're at the helm of
something you're in charge of it for
example a captain or pilot example
Captain Jack Sparrow is at the helm of
the Black Pearl Emma is saying that for
doing such a complicated movie with so
many details you would need a really
capable director and it takes someone
quite special I think to to get all of
that working very well and I think bill
has done a brilliant job of that
somebody that is considered brilliant
has great intelligence or skill tony
stark's visionary genius American
patriot even from an early age the son
of legendary weapons developer Howard
Stark quickly stole the spotlight with
his brilliant and unique mind at age
four he built his first circuit board at
age six his first engine and at 17 he
graduated summa laude from MIT
however in British English brilliant is
used as slang to say that something is
very cool similar to the word awesome in
American English
it's not much it's home I think it's
brilliant
we also wanted to give her this element
of being quite industrious and quite
practical and very inventive somebody
who is considered industrious works very
hard and consistently more commonly we
might say hard working example she is
the most hard-working accountant you
will ever meet somebody who is inventive
has the ability to create or design new
things or to think originally laundry
laundry refers to both the activities of
washing clothes and the dirty clothes
themselves although you could just say I
have to wash my clothes native-speakers
much more often say I have to do my
laundry okay let's do laundry
hey Sheldon hello doin laundry
[Laughter]
of course I'm doing laundry Saturday
night is laundry night and I'm in a
laundry room so every week we make
lessons like this help you understand
natives without getting lost without
missing the jokes and without subtitles
just like this learner from Brazil who
says that he can understand what he
couldn't before and you can improve your
English comprehension too all you have
to do is that subscribe button and the
bell down below so you don't miss any of
our new lessons wood or woods refer to
an area of lamb that is smaller than a
forest but that is covered with trees it
was amazing on earth is used for
emphasis and questions that begin with
the words such as how why what or where
it is often used to suggest that there
is no obvious or easy answer to the
question being asked example how on
earth did that happen why on earth would
he want to go to such a place the green
initiative for only twelve million
dollars will change the way I've heard
enough don't we already have a green
initiative I mean didn't we do a whole
thing hang a banner make a video sting
was there I thought I met sting too did
Mick stings yeah I met sting so why on
earth would we spend another twelve
million dollars though because we can
always do more I can't leave now Sheldon
I'm very busy besides why would I want
to do you a favor after the way you
treated me in the cafeteria what on
earth are you talking about my behavior
in the cafeteria was delightful can you
think of an example with this expression
practice your English by writing it in
the comments below
in the animation Maurice is kind of the
inventor but in this movie it's actually
Belle who is really forging forward and
innovating and coming up with new ways
of doing things which I thought was
really interesting and was my dear that
I loved Belle also does some teaching in
this film she wants to not only does she
love reading for herself but she
actually loves sharing her love of books
and she loves sharing the things that
she finds special and interesting and I
loved that too that she yeah she wants
to share to escape amazing it was a
cruelest treat of all just a lot of
curse the outside world has no place for
a chair like me but it can for you in
the animation Maurice is kind of the
inventor but in this movie it's actually
Belle who is really forging forward and
innovating and coming up with new ways
of doing things to forge ahead or forge
forward is to suddenly make a lot of
progress somebody who is innovating
introduces and suggest improvements and
new ideas to come up with something such
as a plan or solution means to think
about these ideas now if you two don't
mind I'm go to bed before either of you
come up with another clever idea to get
us killed
or worse expelled
Bell also does some teaching in this
film she wants to not only does she love
reading for herself but she actually
loves sharing her love of books and she
loves sharing the things that she finds
special and interesting while the most
correct pronunciation would you probably
learn in school of this word is
interesting natives both Americans and
Brits like Emma often shortened it so it
sounds like interesting notice that it
goes from four syllables interesting to
just three interesting
and interesting necklace oh that's um
interest no no it's not interesting okay
it's very very not interesting it's
actually a hundred percent completely
the opposite of interesting I got across
this happens with other words - how
would you pronounce this you probably
said comfortable
well there is nothing wrong with saying
it this way a native would probably
reduce this to comfortable again
removing one of the syllables this
happens all the time so remember to pay
attention to it in your favorite series
and movies welcome to your new home it's
Mother's but comfortable working Ralph
Lauren can you bring me back some of
those polo shirts well you know what I
don't know if I'd feel comfortable
stealing on my very first day unwilling
to steal from work interesting and she
loves sharing the things that she finds
special and interesting and I loved that
too that she yeah she wants to share
book true you know to escape as we saw
before books allow you to escape and
live in another reality so the Beast is
saying that this book actually or truly
allows you to escape through magic
[Music]
it was her cruelest trick of all just
another curse in fantasy stories it
curse is magical words said to somebody
in order to invoke a supernatural power
and punish or affect someone negatively
[Music]
who's her cruelest trick of all in this
case
tricks simply refers to a clever or
interesting way of doing something
example check out this move I learned
playing soccer the hat trick somebody
who is cruel causes pain and suffering
to others intentionally cruelest means
the most cruel there is nothing that is
more cruel than that it is the
superlative of the adjectives in English
superlatives normally appear as one of
these two options for short adjectives
adjective + S example coolest fastest
smartest Lefou my dearest companion it's
beautiful but of course must I wanted
you to have the finest room in the
castle oh dear for long adjectives most
plus adjectives example most intelligent
most creative most fascinating he taxed
the village to fill his castle with the
most beautiful object we meet and his
parties were the most beautiful
[Music]
you are the wives most gorgeous thing
I've ever seen nobody deserves you it
was her cruelest trick of all it's just
another curse the outside world has no
place for a chair like me would it come
for you did you notice the connected
speech here beast didn't say but it can
for you he said it came for you we here
- interesting instances of morphing T
sounds here first the T of but becomes a
tap T because it is between two vowel
sounds so but it becomes but it this is
more common in American English but
Brits do it sometimes - as beasts does
here and as we saw earlier second the T
of it because it is at the end of this
syllable becomes a stop T sound it it it
came for you hey after you finish this
lesson
be sure to check out this funny lesson
that we made with an ear view of Emma
Watson on The Ellen Show
beating the Beast really if you think
about it is like for movies in one it's
an action movie we're making a
live-action film there's a huge amount
of stunts and there's a wolf fighting
and horse riding and you know and guns
and sword fights and all of that going
on it's also a comedy the comic timing
of characters like Cogsworth and Lumiere
and mrs. Potts
it's just hysterical in my opinion and
then on the other hand it's a romance
[Music]
it's a romantic drama so and then it's a
musical
and then there's music just to just kind
of really added on the top music and
dance and theater really if it isn't the
only bookworm in town so where did you
run off to this week to cities in
northern Italy I didn't want to come
back are you got any new places to go
I'm afraid not
[Music]
but you may reread any of the old ones
that you'd like thank you your library
makes a small corner of the world feel
big so you need you need someone at the
helm of a movie like this they can
really do all of those things and it
takes someone quite special I think to
to get all of that working very well and
I think bill has done a brilliant job of
that we wanted to make sure that we know
she loves reading when he shot to travel
but we also wanted to give her this
element of being quite industrious and
quite practical and very inventive
[Music]
teaching another girl to read isn't one
enough so in the animation Maurice is
kind of the inventor but in this movie
it's actually Belle who is really
forging forward and innovating and
coming up with new ways of doing things
which I thought was really interesting
and was an idea that I loved Belle also
does some teaching in this film she
wants to not only does she love reading
for herself but she actually loves
sharing her love of books and she loves
sharing the things that she finds
special and interesting and I loved that
too that she yeah she wants to share
book that truly allows you to escape
amazing it was a cruelest trick of all
still not a curse the outside world has
no place for creature like me but it can
for you
alright I hope you had as much fun with
that lesson as I did and don't stop the
learning now be sure to improve your
British vocabulary and pronunciation in
this lesson with Emma Watson or check
out all of our lessons with Disney
movies in this playlist now it's time to
go beyond the classroom and live your
English ah haha yeah